CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video, I'd like us to
practice integration by parts.
Specifically, I'd like to solve
the following four problems.
Or I'd like you to solve
I'd like us to find
antiderivatives
for each of these functions.
x e to the minus x,
x cubed over the quantity
1 plus x squared squared,
arctan x, and natural
log x over x squared.
And so the main goal, because
we're using integration
by parts, is to figure out
what you should make u,
and what you should
make v prime.
And why don't you
give it a shot.
Work on that for a little bit.
I'm actually going
to give you one hint,
and that's that this one,
you may want to break up
in a nontraditional way.
You may not want to break
it up as x cubed and 1
over this function.
You're going to want to split up
this function in the numerator.
Part of it will be in u, part
of it will be in v prime.
So that's my hint on number 2.
So now with that information,
I'd like you to give it a shot,
and then I'll come back, and
I'll show you how I do it.
OK, welcome back.
So again, what we're looking
for is antiderivatives for each
of these four functions.
And now, what I'm
going to do, is
I'm going to help you
pick u and v prime,
and then I'm going to show
you what answer I got.
And I'm going to let you
do the work in the middle.
So let's start
off with number 1.
So if I have x e to the
minus x-- integral of x e
to the minus x
dx, it's very easy
to do either-- to make either
e to the minus x either u or v
prime.
Doesn't really matter.
Because an integral
of e to the minus
x is going to have an
e to the minus x again,
and a derivative is going to
have an e to the minus x again,
with a minus sign in
front, in both cases.
But this doesn't really change.
So we have-- when
we go up or down,
it doesn't really matter
if we integrate up
or take a derivative.
So really it's, we
get to pick what
we do with the e to the
minus x based on what
we want to do with the x.
Well, we like taking
derivatives of things
that don't have two functions
of x, so it would be nice if we
chose our integration
by parts pieces
so that this thing
wasn't there anymore.
So let me write down--
actually, before I even
do number 1, maybe
I should remind you
what the integration
by parts formula is.
So let me just, I'll scratch
that out for a second.
And what we're doing,
is we're going to have
integral of u v prime dx.
And if you recall what
you saw in lecture,
is this should be equal to u*v
minus the integral v u prime
dx.
And we'll put that plus c,
because sometimes I forget
to write it at the end.
So I'll put it there,
so I don't forget.
So really, what we're trying
to do, right, is pick the u
and v prime.
And so we want to
make this thing,
this v u prime, as
simple as possible.
So what I was saying is if we
make this v prime or this u,
it doesn't matter.
So let's pick whether we
want this to be u or v prime.
Well, if I make this
u, then u prime is 1.
That's good.
If I make it v prime, then
v is x squared over 2.
That's more complicated.
So we obviously
want to make this u.
So for number 1, we're going
to choose u is equal to x,
and v prime is equal
to e to the minus x.
And then you can
proceed from there.
And I'll leave it at that.
Well, actually, just
to make sure we're OK,
I'll even write u
prime is equal to 1,
and v is going to be equal
to negative e to the minus x.
So we'd be able to
proceed from there, right?
We have all the pieces we need.
Now, number 2-- I'll give you
the final answers at the end.
Number 2, picking u and v prime
is a little more complicated.
And let's look at this function.
x cubed over 1 plus
x squared squared.
The problem with picking--
that does not look like a 2.
Sorry.
The problem with picking
u and v prime here,
is that it's hard to see what's
going to be easy to integrate.
So what we want to
do is rewrite this
as-- let's see-- x
squared times x over 1
plus x squared squared.
And now, why is this any better?
Well, I mean, it's
the same thing.
But why does this help us
see what we want to do?
Well, if you notice this thing
right here-- 1 plus x squared.
What is its derivative?
Its derivative is 2x.
Up here we have an x.
So this piece right
here looks like it
could be much more easily
integrated than this right
here.
So this might be a
little counterintuitive,
because we're going to take
the harder-looking thing,
and make that our v prime.
But the nice thing is
that we can actually
integrate this quantity.
So we choose, in this
case, this is our u,
and this is our v prime.
So how do I integrate this?
Well, I integrate this
by using a substitution.
And that will give me v.
And the derivative of this
is quite simple.
It's just 2x.
Right?
But this is the strategy
that we want here.
Why did we even think to
split that up like that?
Well, we knew we had to
deal with the denominator
in some fashion, and
taking a derivative
with this in the
denominator-- so
putting this part of
the function in u--
when I look at u prime,
it's going to be even worse.
It's going to be a
higher power here.
It's going to be a cubic
in the denominator.
That's just making things worse.
So we know we'd like to
integrate this denominator.
We'd like it to be
a part of v prime.
But the problem is that if I
put all the x cubed in the u,
and if I just had a 1 here
for my v prime, that's, I
can't really integrate
that very well.
But if I keep one
of the x's, then I
can integrate this quite
simply with a substitution.
So that's the sort of
reasoning behind why
we choose it that way.
All right.
We've got two more to
look at, and then I'll
give you the answers.
3.
OK.
3, you've seen
this trick before.
The function was arctan x.
Now, you've seen this
trick I'm about to do
with natural log of x.
The same kind of thing
You actually saw this in
one of the lecture videos.
Because there's only
one function here,
you might think, well, I have
no idea what I'm supposed
to pick for u and v prime.
But remember, it's
really arctan x times 1.
Now I have two functions.
And what gives us a hint for
why we would want to do this,
is that what's the
derivative of arctan x?
Let me just remind you.
d/dx of arctan is 1
over 1 plus x squared.
Right?
We're back to actually an
almost similar situation to what
we had in the previous thing.
d/dx of arctan x is 1
over 1 plus x squared.
So taking a derivative
of this puts it
in a form that almost
looks easy to integrate.
What would make this
function easy to integrate?
If there was an x up
here, instead of a 1.
Then I could use substitution.
Where do we get that
x from when we're
solving this problem, where
we're actually finding
an antiderivative of arctan x?
Well, it's going to come from
the fact that I make this u,
and I make 1 v prime.
So let me write
that out explicitly.
u I make arctan x,
and v prime I make 1.
What does that do
in our formula?
Well, we're going
to be integrating
something that is v u prime.
Well, v is going to be x, and
u prime we see right here.
So it's going to be, I'm going
to be integrating x over 1
plus x squared when I started
doing the integration by parts
method.
That's much simpler, as we
talked about previously,
because the derivative
of x squared is 2x,
and you have an x in
the numerator when
you put in that v.
So this is sort of the flavor
of how these things are actually
working.
So let me do the final one here.
We have ln x over x squared.
OK.
Let me just tell you right now.
In integration by
parts, natural log x
is not something you
want to make the v prime.
You don't want to try and
take an antiderivative.
You know an antiderivative
of natural log of x.
x ln x minus x.
But that's certainly not going
to make things any easier.
Right?
You're actually--
then you've got
a product of two
functions all of a sudden.
Everything's getting
more complicated.
But natural log of x has a very
nice derivative, because you
end up with something that
has just a power of x.
Derivative of natural log
of x is just 1 over x.
So that's probably
the way you always
want to go when you see natural
log of x in these integration
by parts techniques.
Because if I choose u is equal
to ln x, and then v prime.
In this case, I'm going
to write it as a power.
Let's think about what happened.
u prime is 1 over x, right?
So u prime is x to the minus 1.
What's v?
Well, it's something
like, let's see.
Negative x to the minus 1.
Something like that, right?
Let's make sure
I did that right.
Yeah, I think I did that right.
So all of a sudden, if
I integrate v u prime,
that's just a power rule.
It's x to the minus 2,
negative x to the minus 2.
So that's quite
easy to integrate.
So again, when I see natural
log of x in an integration
by parts method,
almost always, I
hate to say always,
almost always,
almost a guarantee that you
want to take a derivative.
You want to make that the u.
So hopefully that makes sense,
some of these strategies.
I tried to pick ones that
were somewhat different,
so you could see some different
types of strategies we needed.
And now I've done these earlier.
So I'm just going to write
down what the answers actually
are, and you can
compare to what you got.
So the answer to number
1, just to check.
Number 2.
Some of these are kind of long.
Number 3.
Number 4.
So let's just go through.
We get-- in number 1, we get
negative x e to the minus x
minus e to the minus x plus c.
Number 2, we get
negative x squared
over 2 times 1 plus x squared
plus 1/2 natural log 1 plus x
squared plus c.
Three is x arc tan x minus 1/2
natural log of the quantity 1
plus x squared plus c, and
four is negative natural log
x over x minus 1 over x plus c.
So again, the whole point of
this exercise, in my mind,
is really to make sure we
get a good understanding of,
when we're doing integration
by parts, which function makes
the most sense to have as u, and
which function makes the most
sense to have as v prime.
So that was the main
point of this exercise.
Hopefully you're starting
to get a flavor for how
these problems actually work.
And I think I will stop there.